hey what is up everybody it's axel here
for anime uproar and today i will be
discussing
everything that we know about the king
of curses ryoman sukuna
while much of his character is still
shrouded in mystery there is definitely
still quite a lot to talk about when it
comes to this demonic
tattooed ma champ and i for one can't
wait to get into it
if you enjoy this video and want to see
more jiu jitsu kaizen content on this
channel be sure to leave a like and
maybe consider leaving a comment with
who you'd like to see me talk about next
it'll only take a second but it's a huge
help for the channel and hey if you
haven't subscribed to anime uproar make
this the video that you subscribe
and be sure to click that bell to select
all notifications
you can also follow anime uproar on
twitter and instagram at
anime uproar or you can follow myself at
excellionyt
speaking of which since we had so many
commenters who seemed confused in the
last video
i just wanted to remind everyone who i
am and why i'm here
my name is axel and i've been an editor
on anime uproar for a few years now and
when they started getting bombarded with
requests to cover jujutsu kaizen on
their channel they asked me to step
in and start making videos since they're
already covering so many other series
and their plates are so full as it is
so hopefully you enjoy the content
finally this video will contain jiu
jitsu kaizen manga spoilers so please
proceed with caution
you have been warned so obviously we are
introduced to sukuna almost immediately
in the story
however his own story begins a thousand
years ago
this era was known as the golden age of
jiu jitsu sorcery
and among all of the sorcerers tsukuna
was by far the most powerful
this was to the point that despite being
human he was often called an imaginary
demon
that being said even though he is human
in the flashback that we see or the
legend that gojo reveals to us
we see him standing as this four-eyed
four-armed monster
surrounded by flames which you know
not the most human looking dude i've
ever seen this man
was an absolute force of nature though
and it took a large group of other
sorcerers banding together to fight at
their absolute best to take him down
however death was far from the end for
sukuna
because he had such a wealth of cursed
energy upon his death he transformed
into a curse himself
this is kind of interesting because
ghetto's goal is to eliminate normal
humans so that only sorcerers remain
this is because sorcerers have better
control over their cursed energy
and when they die they're less likely to
become curses themselves
so it's a little bit strange that one of
the people who debatably was the
strongest curse energy sorcerer in
history
excluding gojo and maybe a few other
cases would become a curse himself
regardless in order to contain this
powerful curse the 20 fingers which it
was divided between were sealed away as
cursed objects
however their power would continue to
grow over time and by the time that
yugi's story begins
the steels are beginning to weaken of
course the occult members would
completely unseal one finger and yuji
would go on to eat that
and with some of zukuno's energy now
being released the rest of the fingers
start to resonate and more rapidly draw
in the curses around them
by this point in the manga we've seen
yuji eat about 15
fingers meaning there are only a few
left however each time he does
tsukuna becomes all that much more
powerful within him and his takeovers
become harder and harder to suppress
i feel like i have to bring up the
elephant in the room when we talk about
sukuna's curse and his 20 fingers
and that is what happened to the rest of
his body is it the case that only the
fingers remain or is the rest of his
body out there somewhere as well just
waiting to be reunited with them
it's definitely something i'm super
curious about as the idea of only being
fingers is a little bit strange to me
regardless of if there is more to his
body or not though
one thing is for sure and that's that
we're getting dangerously close to yuji
having all 20 of them together
and that means they have to reach a
resolution about what to actually do
with him
will he be executed as planned or will
he somehow be saved
speaking of reasons to execute yuji
though let's talk about some of sukuna's
abilities and powers and try to figure
out
why everyone's so terrified of his
revival firstly just
on a base level we can pretty clearly
see that he has some incredible
mastery of cursed energy and he can use
it both offensively
and for healing we've seen him grow
limbs back on yuji's body we've seen him
bring yuji back to life
and much more keep in mind when we saw
him doing these things he only had a few
fingers
just a fraction of his full power and on
top of that he was in yuji's body rather
than his own
and because of that it's just kind of
hard to imagine what he would be able to
do at his full strength
it really makes you wonder what it must
have taken to defeat the original sukha
in the first place if he can just heal
things
so easily even in terms of the limited
power that he has
it can be a little bit difficult to
gauge sukuna we've only seen him fight a
handful of times but in most cases the
fights we have are over in a flash
specifically we can see him ending
fights with the finger bearer and yuji
without really seeing what happens a
moment passes and in both cases they
just get sliced apart with
no real visual cues or at least very
minimal we also see him killing the
twins
nanako and mimiko without any effort at
all and even against
extremely powerful curses and cursed
users like jogo mahito and shigemo
tsuganot just toys with them he straight
up makes a game of jogo and shigemo is
cut in half without him even knowing
the gap between tsukuna and the others
is immeasurable
we've only really seen two fights
involving sukuna that demonstrated
any real sense of struggle or effort
being exerted
firstly with his 10 second fight with
gojo at the start of the story
and here we see gojo treating tsukuna
the same way that sukuna treated jogo
even sitting on him at one point after
tsukun's attack
but again this is sukuna with one finger
and we don't really know how much he's
being limited in this state
of course if you ask gojo it's pretty
obvious who would win the fight though
even if sukuna was fully revived
and then we have his fight with maharaga
this wasn't exactly a close
fight however it did take some serious
thinking on sukuna's part maharaga is a
shikigami summoned by megumi and its key
strength is adaptability
basically if any attack hits him and
hurts him he will adapt to become more
or less immune to it going forward
to this sukna opens his domain and
unleashes a barrage of attacks on the
shikigami until it's
pretty much at its limits and before he
can begin healing
tsukuna launches a massive fireball to
eliminate the monster
so in general we can probably place
tsukuna in the top two
if not three strongest characters in the
series and the interesting part of this
is that despite this power
his abilities are very simple in a
series where characters can summon these
10
shadow shikigami or control robots
remotely or
be a panda it seems that the more simple
and easy to understand ability is
the more powerful it is toto can clap to
swap places gojo
can push and pull things and sukuna can
cut things
at the core of sukhna's abilities is
just that cutting
specifically he's able to do it in two
varieties though dismantle which is used
to cut
inanimate objects and cleave which takes
into account
the target's level of cursed energy and
toughness before slashing into them to
ensure that they can be destroyed in one
cut
these are more useful when combined with
his domain expansion malevolent shrine
this creates a 200 meter radius in which
tsukuna can create this never-ending
barrage of these two slices
until his target or just everything
around him is completely destroyed
the reason sukun's domain is so large
when compared to others in the series
is because he doesn't create a barrier
around it by giving his opponents the
ability to escape he drastically
increases the range and power of his own
domain
and if you want more information on how
domains work in general be sure to check
out our last video
discussing them finally while tsukuna's
abilities are supposed to be based on
slashes he also uses a fire attack when
he's fighting maharaga and jogo he
explains to jogo that a curse wouldn't
know about this ability
but he wouldn't bother explaining
further so it seems like there might be
some kind of special ability which
allows especially powerful jiu-jitsu
sorcerers to possibly
unlock a second trait this is something
i would love to see expanded on if
that's the case
especially for characters like toto who
i guess we could say
could use a hand when it comes to his
own clapping ability now
finally the last thing we have to talk
about in regards to sukuna is his
binding vowel
there are a ton of questions when it
comes to this man but above all else i
am more curious about this than anything
when itadori died early in the series he
was brought to sukhuma's realm within
himself
here sukuna agrees to revive yuji if he
abides by two conditions
of course yuji rejects this and instead
they decide to have a fight to the death
if yuji can manage to win he'll be
revived with no vow no conditions
and if he loses oh there goes his head
i guess it was chopped off before he
could even finish that thought
well you know what they say don't make
deals with thousand-year-old curses
because they'll surprise attack you and
cut your head in half
a very specific piece of wisdom but very
valuable nonetheless
anyways having won their wager sukuna
imposes these conditions
firstly he is able to take control of
yuji for a full minute at a period
of his choosing that being said he did
originally make a promise that he
wouldn't kill anyone while he was in
control
but this was part of the original deal
that was shot down by yuji before they
made the bet on fighting to the death
so who knows if sukuna will uphold that
stipulation
and second the condition is that yuji
will completely forget
about making this binding vowel this is
the ultimate chekhov's gun
we know it's going to happen but we just
don't know when
or why tsukuna will cash this in but it
will be something huge
when he does so now i have a question
for all of you
what do you think sukuna wants with this
one minute if he doesn't mind not
killing people
we can rule out eliminating people like
gojo or any other possible threats so
there has to be something left that we
still don't know about
possibly a way to free himself once all
20 fingers have been gathered
but that is just about everything we
have now about the king of the curses
sukuna so far
he is definitely up there with some of
the coolest characters in the series in
my opinion
probably my third or fourth favorite but
what do you guys think about him
and do you think he can really use more
than one curve straight
if so that could be a real game changer
if you enjoyed this jujutsu kaizen video
and want to see more please leave a like
and if you're new to anime upload
remember to subscribe and ring the bell
by selecting all notifications you can
help guarantee that you will not miss
any videos in the future
that being said like i mentioned earlier
we have a video discussing domain
expansion which we released earlier on
in the week
and we also have a video talking about
gojo's powers so if you want to go check
those out you definitely can
and of course you can follow anime
uproar at anime uproar on twitter and
instagram or you can follow myself at
excellionyt
i want to give a big thank you to the
patron squad over on patreon who helped
make videos like this possible
first and foremost i want to thank the
patron of legend the one
acknowledged by lord twigo himself alpha
sigma
and our the one tier patrons the ones
who stand atop all clans
ingrada pate heffa al-jatal dr cortman
the toasted chi emperor otaku spidey
life tinel
tungsten tarkis baked buddhist cody
hebert and
monkey d quilly and of course our pro
hero patrons the one and only gilgamesh
the red haired raven
angel crews anatoly kazatsky very gucci
alicia actor bonnie parks hinokami and
water joanne garcia
ted no ted fatboy games corey mcgohan
metal mama deadly saint and soul rye
slice and dice
thank you all so much if you do enjoy
the work on this channel you can go over
to patreon.com
anime uproar and support the channel for
as little as one dollar a month
if you do so you will get your name
featured in future videos alongside
these amazing people right here
and of course you'll also get access to
the anime uproar exclusive patreon
discord where we talk about anime life
and of course dank memes so check out
patreon.com
anime uproar link in the description if
you're interested
thanks again and until next time stay
excellent
[Music]
you